Sean Connor Sean Connery yeah I did a  movie with Sean in Spain how was how is  he he was so great Sean uh very down to  earth Scotsman uh you know this just  this assault of the earth kind of guy  who also was a very very conscientious  actor and would love to run scenes and  rehearse and and and do the work you  know Sean didn't just show up he knew  what he was doing so yeah he didn't just  uh depend on that amazing Sean Connery  Charisma he was also somebody who worked  hard at it what do you talk to Sean  Connery about at dinner oh everything  everyone what did he want well he wanted  to talk he wanted to talk about golf  which wasn't very interesting to me